well police here in New York have
tightened security after a recent string
of attacks against people of Jewish
faith officials say they can handle that
and New Year's Eve security including
the Times Square celebration they have
been preparing for all year organized
practice the midnight ball dropped
yesterday and our Lola Lange he is in
Time Square which will be packed with
people tonight molla what do police
expect there well good morning guys you
know police are expecting this to be one
of the most well policed well protected
places on the planet as an estimated one
and a half million people have prepared
to end the current decade and bring in
the new decade here in Times Square we
asked the NYPD counterterrorism chief
just what it takes to keep a party like
this safe our super bowl to do so this
is it this is the big show this is what
we wait for all year long ever since
last year's ball drop
[Applause]
New York Police have been preparing for
this year's decade ending celebration
what's all the security on the ground
there oh it's multi-layered on every
access point you will go through it
numerous steps of screening from nagato
meters to explosive vapor canines and
then heavy weapons team you'll see
NYPD assistant chief Martine Matarazzo
oversees the counterterrorism Bureau
she says nearly the entire department
thousands of officers both in uniform
and in plain clothes will secure Times
Square with forces on the ground and
with the help of drones and helicopters
in the sky questions over New Year's Eve
security in Manhattan have risen in
response to Saturday night's stabbing at
a rabbis home just miles from New York
City which left five people wounded I'd
like to reassure people there are no
credible threats but here on CTM
yesterday New York police commissioner
Dermot Shea told the million-plus people
expected to watch the ball drop this you
will be very safe in Times Square it's a
sentiment echoed by assistant chief
Matarazzo
considering all the security this is
probably gonna be a pretty safe place oh
absolutely it's gonna be the safest
place on earth
well New York of course is not the only
place reacting to acts of violence this
New Year's Eve we reached out to police
in Dallas of course after the recent
church shooting there and nearby white
settlement spokesperson of the Dallas
Police Department told us that they will
provide extra patrol at places of
worship David mola thank you very much
you